all right it's fair to say that
battlefield 2042's beta could have been
better after the press preview event and
the limited early access beta
battlefield 2042 opened the floodgates
for a weekend allowing everyone to gain
access to the beta and reactions were
understandably mixed the rose tinted
lenses are off now and some of my
initial hype has died down despite my
earlier video where i had almost nothing
but praise and excitement for the beta
so let's break down some key parts of
the beta now that it's fully wrapped up
and see what was good and what looks
like it needs some serious work ahead of
the full game's release obligatory shout
out for your likes and subs because come
on now it's battlefield we're gonna have
a lot more to share with you leading up
to launch and you won't want to miss it
so good news you're bad news let's start
with the good news first yeah so right
off the bat there was a lot of curiosity
on how battlefield 2042 would handle
destruction and to that a good old
tornado would like to introduce itself
the tornado is an absolute highlight in
my honest opinion and is one that i
think a lot of other folks agree with it
is an awesome in-game event that can
happen totally at random and at
different parts of the map it's pretty
novel right now and there could come a
time where that wears off but as of
right now the tornado is a highlight to
me plain and simple alongside the
tornado destruction makes its return
although maybe not quite to the extent
of bad company 2's awesome destruction
where you could just level buildings
into the ground but still i've seen a
few distinct videos from reddit or
youtube showing off really awesome
destruction
that makes me really hopeful for
destruction at launch on all the other
maps after all battlefield is nothing
without destruction so it is absolutely
no surprise to me that the chaos of
destruction and levolution passes this
initial test
all right not quite bad but not exactly
great either the graphics seem to have a
mix of reactions barring xbox one and
ps4 players most of the players in the
beta probably got to enjoy the pretty
solid overall visuals of the game on
xbox series x ps5 and pc although that
is totally subjective which is okay
there may very well be a bunch of you in
the comments that thought the game
looked awful which i understand i played
the beta on pc and despite the visual
bugs and glitches i thought the game
looked okay for what it was to be honest
after all i was more focused on
maximizing my time with the build i also
think that the game being just maybe one
or two steps above the graphics of
battlefield 4 is a necessary evil since
we're ramping up the lobby size to 128
players on pc and current gen consoles
trade-offs with in-game graphics for
performance are gonna be necessary which
explains why i'm probably gonna see
folks making war zone comparisons in
terms of the visual fidelity
this one might be controversial but i
was actually really enjoying my time
with the specialists mckay is my guy i
love the intrinsic perks and the added
dynamism to the meta with having these
specialists reading more online and
talking to friends and colleagues alike
that played the beta i can see the
downside of the specialists too they
come at the expense of the original
battlefield classes classes were the
backbone of the battlefield player
giving you a customizable loadout within
a boundary based on what kind of a
playstyle you wanted the assault
engineer support and recon classes were
all meant to be played a certain way and
their kits supported that playstyle with
specialists that's kind of out the
window sure your specialist ability
tries to keep you in that framework for
example you're not gonna be scouting
with folk you know her healing dart
still puts her squarely in that medic
role but you can still take out
helicopters with anti-air rockets like
something just doesn't fit i easily
ignored most of this when i was playing
the beta because it is a video game if
i'm gonna suspend my disbelief and
grapple onto a rocket launcher up to the
ozone i can believe that falk is capable
of blowing up a couple of helicopters i
pick my battles so yeah i personally
thought specialists were fun but plenty
of people out there preferred the
operators of old and i can completely
see where they're coming from if
anything i'm gonna make a bold claim and
say that it's not the specialists that
are a big problem it's the non-class
specific weapons and gadgetry there are
too many people running around with
launchers and no one is playing support
battlefield is all about squads and
synergy among the chaos and right now
all we have are a bunch of chaos and a
bunch of lone wolves
all right customization has been another
hot topic among the community and from
what i understand also a mixed result
personally i welcome change i don't
always like it but i find that when
mechanics and gameplay changes knew that
the battlefield franchise are applied
the potential grows a perfect example is
the in-game attachment system also
referred to as the plus system i like it
i really do i know a lot of folks will
disagree which is okay honestly but it's
just how i feel it feels nice being able
to swap from iron sights to a red dot
and to mess with different parts of the
gun on the fly the system could totally
be just a gimmick which many content
creators seem to feel is the case but i
don't know if you've seen my other
videos you know that i'm obsessed with
destiny and that game is all about
tweaking your loadout and build crafting
so this kind of light express style
customization is totally in my
wheelhouse but i understand if it feels
unnecessary to others
alright your mileage may vary here
particularly if you're on controller
versus mouse and keyboard but the
vehicles in the beta did not feel good
to me at all
like at all i couldn't get in the swing
of things and call me crazy but if a
vehicle is handling worse than a warthog
from halo we have a problem the call-in
vehicle system was interesting but it
also felt a little off after some time
similar to the in-game attachment plus
system calling in vehicles didn't really
stick with players like dice may have
hoped although once again this beta is
from an older build and we only had like
half a week to really see it in action
i'm confident that the more players use
these systems in practice over time the
more normalized and viable these
additions become but the core gameplay
loop of those vehicles
yeah not so good
i was a fan of the huge verticality that
one building offered and the orbital map
as well as the rocket launch station
directly across from it the rest of the
map though was whatever it was also huge
despite it being considered one of the
more moderate sized maps orbital was
also just super open which felt boring
after a while especially on the infantry
side of things vehicles will thrive and
an important factor to help navigate
these maps is bringing things like that
colon system into a necessity but as
mentioned earlier the handling on those
vehicles just sucked like i cannot get
over that they really do feel like they
go hand in hand it doesn't help that
conquest is the bread and butter of
battlefield and that game mode doesn't
just sit as well with these large maps
as it may have in battlefield 3 or 4.
the levolution is excellent as
levolutions tend to be but there's very
little else about orbital that felt like
something worth championing which is
unfortunate battlefield maps can be hit
or miss depending on which game you're
playing but they all tend to have
distinct characteristics or aesthetics
short of the rocket launch everything
else about orbital felt incredibly dull
especially after my initial excitement
wore off from the first several matches
i think poor optimization has to be the
standout for me out of all the things
that could be the worst takeaway from
the beta my colleagues and friends
started telling me that they could
barely get the game to run not long
after my initial preview for the beta
went live the optimism that i originally
had started to dwindle as i continued to
play i played on pc throughout the
entire beta and my rig isn't top of the
line but it's definitely not bad either
even with a 1080 ti and an i9 processor
i had to lower the graphic settings down
a few notches because i was running into
performance issues now imagine the
frustration of folks online with 30 80s
saying that they were running into less
than ideal frame rates and all of this
doesn't even scratch the surface of
significant issues people face trying to
play on console last gen support needs
to be dropped from large online
multiplayer games in my mind going
forward this might be a controversial
statement with the lack of readily
available next-gen consoles due to
garbage scalpers but the truth is that
old gen hardware is significantly
hindering games like battlefield 2042
that are trying to push barriers with
their ambition you can't have massive
maps in huge 128 player lobbies on old
architecture xbox one and ps4 just
cannot keep up and those builds suffered
the most visual glitches long load times
and having trouble even just getting the
game to work on those platforms makes
the whole experience awful there were
persisting problems that went beyond
last gen consoles unfortunately poor
optimization leads to less than ideal
experiences for ps5 and series x owners
as well although not nearly as bad as
those on the xbox one and ps4 i'm still
telling myself that if dice chooses to
move forward with the recently delayed
november release the game will be in a
significantly better state than the beta
that we received however the reports of
poor performance across the board in
some capacity or another are concerning
listen man all of this aside i'm holding
the faith whatever dice decides to do i
am going to support and i expect growing
pains nothing is ever perfect and in
2021 games are almost expected to have
post launch support for a very long time
i hope that battlefield only has to deal
with launch day server issues
temporarily because it's bound to not be
pretty if the issues listed earlier
continue let's not understate all the
good that we got to glimpse from the
beta despite the negatives and please
keep in mind that this build was old by
several months and whatever dice is
currently iterating right now is not the
same as what we played also note that we
only saw one game mode and map and that
the core gameplay loop was still as
solid as ever firefights are fun and
weapon engagements are a thrill despite
some balance issues you have levolutions
and extreme weather events like the
tornadoes triumphantly demanding
attention each match which is a delight
to me not to mention we still have
battlefield portal in the brand new
hazard zone to look forward to i am
confident that if there are any issues
dice will be sure to do their damnedest
to fix them if they could do it with
battlefield 4 they can do it here sound
off in the comments what you thought and
be sure to tell me what you're hopeful
for with battlefield 2042 if you clicked
on this video odds are you love
battlefield and you want the best for
this game just like i do so i welcome
all of your thoughts tell me what you
hope to see in the comments below and
we'll share as we learn more about
hazard zone or any other big news on
battlefield until next time